n'ayant que 18 minutes j'attaque dans le
coeur de tout homme de tout ramener à
des forces créatrices qui sommeille qui
origine de la tendre enfance et qui se
manifeste pas le rêve mais là ces forces
vives qui sont dans nos coeurs d'enfants
très tôt sont étouffés par les pressions
familiales sociales économiques
professionnels et parfois matrimoniale
et ses forces vives ne devienne plus que
murmure on les étoffes on lisait tout
bascule dès la petite école exemple la
petite céline d'un coin qui écoute son
professeur mais qui n'est pas là elle
est dans la lune elle rêve
le professeur valises et céline tuerait
tudor sort de la lune veulent accéder
nous serons capables de se lever et dire
monsieur le professeur
avec tout le respect que je vous dois
excusez-moi j'ai droit de rêver ne
touche pour mon rêve la différence
atteint l'animal peine humain c'est que
l'animal marche par instinct parce que
d'humains est capable de rêver le rêve
s'est pris de passion d'émotion de
créativité d'originalité
quels résultats quel enfer ans les gens
s'éloignent de ses forces vives ne les
écoute plus donc conscience de l'utilité
de leur vitalité et sec demande et
pression et les fronts terre regarde
dovi regarder nos vies que de pression
que de contestation quand d'opposition
que des dénigrements cas d'insécurité
regardez ce qui nous est imposé les gens
ne font à peu près jamais ce qu'elles
jouent les frais c'est un second choix
une alternative une panacée et ses
taureaux comme on dit est posée
accidentelle occasionnels et alors les
gens se surprennent n'a pas performé a
pas réussi après tu es fier mais pire
que ce rapport est heureux de revenir un
jour je serai capable de son fait de ce
mail de son futur de ces dix de ses
destinées de son devenir
il ya un mot de passe qui nous est
imposé le désir d un le désir des autres
sont pas nécessairement ce qui te
convient ce kit abeilles bien ce thème
sont peut-être pas les mieux placés pour
dicter son futur temps d'amener la
patiente la résignation le défaire 6
l'acceptation mois ne sont pas des
vertus que je préconise il faut libérer
son armée sont
la violence des coeurs les satisfactions
et de la frustration qui s'y joue comme
on dit souvent prenons soin nos cordes
que notre armée envie d'y rester dit de
bris alors je regarde des biens il ya
deux éléments armés vie - qui bon maquis
j'attaque genève grâce à la passion
d'une vie le brassard
on était cultivateur il y avait une
grosse tu veux m dos il fallait la
remplir d'eau d'électricité de départ
rendu est là qu on allait à la pompe est
mécaniquement manuellement une pompe on
arrive un peu de laque eu ma part m'a
fait découvrir qu'il y avait dans la cus
quatre ou cinq petites abeilles en train
de se noyer
alors papa m'a forcé matt mendois et les
petites abeilles on monte sur mon doigt
je les ai sauvé de la noyade et ils ont
eu la liberté dans mon cas temps froid
d'un entomologiste et enée maman elle
l'était généreuse marin obliger à nous
sommes donné deux cadeaux dans mon test
à deux il fallait que j'en donnais un
petit pose un enfant défavorisé même un
aspect dans mon camp les graines de
générosité pas drôle de donner 5 1% ton
cadeau comme l'impôt fédéral 50 % c'est
c'est pas mal dans mon coeur était mené
et msm excuses
un humaniste j'aime les insectes une
entomologiste vous le savez tous soudés
insectes passionnés des insectes
j'ai donné ma vie aux sincères mais il
fut aussi un humaniste mais insectes
c'est un peu juste pour moi c'est
apparemment ce que j'aime cela qui
appartient ce que j'aime vraiment les
québécois
quand j'ai voulu faire c'est à dire de
montréal souffre pas le franchement moi
ça vous la pause aniesa ce talent dont
la stature à financer l'économie et à
baho tout le monde me dit shlomo bbc to
you on n'a pas tant parler d'un simple
ruisseau mois pour réussir à convaincre
la ville de montréal
j'ai écrit à toronto dans l'autre ou
toronto où on m'a envoyé une lettre je
n'ai douté j'ai pris la retraite j'ai
photocopié la tête je me suis fait un
but je suis qu'il y a moins de belnet
par la toro rosso de toronto comme quoi
qui qui voulait avoir un secteur il faut
je travaillais comme une menace beaucoup
à impliquer les gens à développer chez
eux le goût de l'entrepreneuriat de
l'entrepreneurship comme on dit qu'il se
découvre même qu'ils découvrent leur
talent leur passé on est plein on crève
à l'ail à utiliser 10 12 15 pour faire
notamment
alors j'essaye d'amener les jeunes en
particulier a excellé à être re trouver
leur vocation leur fonction leur espace
leur place dans cette vie de rêve parce
qu'on vit dans un leader on vit dans une
vidéo l'air dans un pays de rêve
moi je donne des conférences un bon
cavalier se vend il refuse d'aller loin
moi je vois personne d'abord me voir
c'est pourquoi chez bouquins mauvois
j'appelle au témiscamingue sakur tan je
vois loin en gaspésie quand j'arrive
dans ses candidats lors utiliser une
expression vulgaire les gens me disent
pour un homme devenu réalité je n'aime
pas ces expressions vous dire je vois
utiliser l'anglais que tout le monde le
comprenne et monde et l'escroc d'ap
faveur des jeunes de 8 10 12 15 ans qui
me disent tout et ce cloud à l'école et
screwed up
les professeurs et son trou doc haye la
famille est ce que vous donne la
politique qu'est ce que vous donne
raison à les écouter tout escroc de
vergnette claude à comment on vit dans
un pays de rêve
pays d'eau des lacs de montagne devient
un pays immense où on est fort peu
nombreux à regarder
ils sont 25 millions aux ein
ils sont tannés vous bien ça peut être
bon c'est ce que je veux vous dire là
ils sont 27 mille personnes par
kilomètre carré
en chine ils sont 44 mille personnes par
pizzo on est quatre fois quatre milles
selon k il ya pas de place n'a pas de
futur papa ta place dans ce pays de rêve
un pays d'eau des lacs de montagne un
pays où le chef naturel et une autre
chose que je dis à ces jeunes là on à
lévis oui la vie tu veux tuer ou les
bataillons oui on a la vie la vie c'est
grand c'est beau c'est énorme c'est
unique
on dirait une vie ça vaut rien mais rien
ne vaut plus que des vies tout via son
centre sava la signification son
importance
son utilité il n'y a pas de vies
inutiles
mon budget autrement l'insecte tutu
bêtement comme ça au sol que tu es
classe dans un geste d'orgueil
insignifiant qui est tu dois t'en revenu
sur cette dernière pour décider que ce
petit insecte l'on ne doit pas venir
notre n'avait pas survivre parce qu'il
est petit accepterais tu doit par
exemple être écrasé par un gros
dinosaures s'il existe encore je dirais
une chose moi je prenais pour
techniquement n'importe quoi tu
respectes mois il faut respecter la vie
toute vie à son sens sa valeur et puis
voyez vous moi cette passerelle dans mon
cas j'ai été contestés ben oui ne n'est
prophète dans son pays ben oui qui était
contestée merci à tous ceux qui m'ont
contacté
parce que moi comme vous me connaissez
moi tout ce bitume et call put une
comtesse touche performe jeu comme un
insecte qui s'agitent
alors j'ai plus mauvais oeil sur les
insectes mais oui j'ai été contestée
mais limogés laissé une note avant cette
profession notariale collectionner des
insectes des égouts de singapour mon
père qu'apportait papa il me dit pas
renié continue à contester ces pépins il
n'y a pas une cenne à faire avec ça tu
vois le niveau
mme amarelle maudissant massa de la
maison ça pue csap examen merci maman
j'ai été contacté laurent m'a donné des
surnoms une mouche qui le piquer il ya
des bébés dans take il ya des fourmis
des rames
il cherche des poux il ya des plus
entraînants des mois les parasites et
maladies selon les beatles le bloc mène
habituellement l'homme aux insectes
d'abord de fly mène les limes diana john
désert
mais bon malgré tout j'ai continué mes
voyages mes expéditions boisjoly dans
une centaine 140 pays étudiés il dit
j'ai observé j'ai accumulé d'énormes
collection riche et moins jeunes et à
des 450 mille spécimens
j'ai eu tort aux collectionneurs en
fiducie il trace non pas pour le moins
oui pour les autres jeux ouverts en
interne allemand vous avez fait
sincérité division qui s'appelle mémoire
d'un siècle une autre qui s'appelle
insectes pour sensibiliser des humains
mon but était de réconcilier des humains
avec un animal qui a beaucoup de classe
la classe des insectes
le programme est possible tout cas c'est
d'un enfant a été passifs ou joujou un
insectarium par exemple en chine à
chailles chinoise honoré lost inférieur
il y avait un stage à peu près de 150
tout en couleurs où les autres en
espèces ont voyagé à l'époque ils m'ont
donné 250 kg cadeau même pour et oui
comment
mach est revenue mal à l'aéroport de
tahiti et ça me prendra toute la nuit au
verso merci beaucoup et fait masser sur
la passion et d'émotion
la d'éducation pour en arriver un jour à
l'elysée montréal ça rêve cette année
puis la cuve de la réaction de mes
parents me sonel ce rêve et hénin aussi
un petit peu en souffrance dans la
douleur d'un creuset de la souffrance
que sa personne les jambes forte en
réussir enfin un jour à créer
l'insectarium de montréal
c'était le premier depuis les amériques
quelle fierté pour doter québec mais on
est habitué aux dégâts
après des premières mais pas n'importe
active n'est pas n'importe quoi
on est habitué à regarder notre regarder
notre transparence notre notre
performance dans la même désordre
cinéma la culture la littérature modique
on performe
non c'est surtout de la cei est
d'enseigner aux jeunes aux élèves je
vois dans des classes
moi je vois des étudiants d'un collège
jean sèye par mes conférences par un mon
action à les valoriser
vous voyez-vous l'insectarium il
performe une institution comme ça c'est
dimensionnelle c'est vocationnelle et
l'injecté rien mais c'est en relation
avec la science avec l'environnement
avec l'écologie la conservation
l'éducation la culture la muséologie le
loisir récréatif
tu peux aller là à l'insectarium avec
des enfants il n'y a pas de pornographie
l'eau il n'y a pas de violence
c'est beau c'est propre c'est peu c'est
pas dangereux poursuit rendu notre corps
il face à jack buser il travaille il
fait comme moi regardez moi après avoir
été copiés plagié humilié l'avez compris
je pense que c'est un post-it fonctions
et puis regardez il ya c'est un fait sur
l'assaut mon but est de réconcilier des
humains avec une classe ya beaucoup de
classe donc j'ai pas toutes sortes de
main d'homme d'action pour sensibiliser
les gens mais ça lui dire à tomber
fantastique pour le québec et c'est à
dire mais des copies étaient plus âgés
tout le monde la voit des insectes
abeilles hommes comme je vous dis j'en
et attendent leur avait plein de
commandes de 50 ans à seul avec ma femme
pour les failles j'y vais mais la ville
est retombé aussi pour d'autres annonces
à gré des contrats faramineux pour des
films québécois dans le domaine du
design dans ce domaine de la
communication - les nationalistes
québécois c'est des firmes québécoises
que j'essaye de diriger ces contrats et
non pas de resserrement aux états unis
où il ya eu des retombées fantastique et
vous je vous annonce aussi que très
bientôt on va nous relie au monde
n'aurait peut-être pas tout de suite la
population aurait les chapines l animal
des insectes
alors je vais fabriquer une énorme
magnifique tueur je vous en avertit une
énorme magnifique tueur vous le savez
bien d'insectes et je vais fanny du
public et
là dedans des insectes ont beau faire
c'est à dire que ça mange les uns des
autres le mot s'agissant de berck tu as
marre j'en ai les autres ou oublié de
nous prenez-vous ça va bien ah ouais une
mouche une mouche drosophile par exemple
est la manufacture
croyez le ou pas quelle génération part
était de mouches
nous autres humains on note quatre par
siècle mouais été après 25 en amont
exotiques 15 par année dans un uniforme
et aux e-mails et très intéressé mais
elle est très intéressée à mettre la
main là dessus alors dans une boîte sur
le jeune amar en grand je vais élever
des clics et des sirènes des mouches
drosophiles des télés brion et je vois
fabriquer un pat où on retrouve 85%
protéines pour honorer nos animaux avec
ça les poulets de saint-hubert barbecue
par exemple au lieu de peser deux kilos
- j ai mis mon peser 3 kg au lieu de
pompe la semaine pour arriver à maturité
les miens mon arrivée à maturité après
neuf semaines
imagine-toi l'économique ça représente
la voiture pacifique soit c'est possible
ça c'est pas pour moi il va être trop
tard moi je reçois les quinze ans
s'achève mais ce que je veux vous dire
jusqu'à la fin on doit aimer insectes ma
passion avant de bien des patients
effectuent eux je bossais sur moi une
passion incestueuse est bon je termine
là dessus en me disant celui que
j'appelle ans sa passion c'est
saint-augustin qu'il a dit a moins perdu
que celui qui a perdu la passion des
amitiés vont apprécier